Emma et Emy de Coralie sodo et Raphaël
Michot chez Epsilon
jeunesse Emma et Emie sont ami depuis si
longtemps qu'aucune des deux ne saurait
dire depuis quand elle ne se quitte
jamais bien sûr emma a souvent dû
attendre Emy qui fait tout au ralenti
mais elle a appris la patience désormais
les deux amis prennent leur temps les
journées s'écoulent doucement et se
ressemblent le matin au marché Emy porte
le cabat de retour à la maison Emma
prépare le repas emma va chercher le
courrier Emy rempl les papiers et quand
Emy nettoie le parquet Emma s'occupe des
toiles
d'araignées aujourd'hui c'est jour de
fête Emmy souffle ses 123 bougies malgré
les apparences elle est encore jeune
pour une tortue de son espèce
Emma quant à elle est devenue une
vieille dame et se sent vite fatiguée
préparer un joli gâteau pour son amie
lui a demandé beaucoup d'énergie mais
elle est tellement heureuse de lui faire
plaisir elle lui offre un petit paquet
facile à déballer
Emy découvre une carte du monde avec un
chemin tracé au crayon elle comprend
qu'Emma veut voyager et trouve que c'est
une merveilleuse
idée au petit matin les deux amis
prennent la route Emma porte sa besacee
Emy porte Emma sur sa carapace elle
croise quelques passants ébahis
ma sourit et s'écrit mon amie et moi
allons au bout du monde alors parfois un
monsieur une dame ou un groupe d'enfants
répond en souriant mais à cette allure
vous n'êtes pas arrivé et Emma enchantée
se plaît à ajouter nous ne sommes pas
pressés nous avons toute la vie devant
nous les journées passent et ne se
ressemblent plus Emma et Emie se
régalent du paysage qui défile sans fin
elle profite de chaque instant et le
soir elle trouve un couvert et un lit
pour
Emma parfois elle reste plusieurs jours
au même endroit pour se reposer et
partager le quotidien des gens qu'elle
rencontre puis elles reprennent leur
périple de ville en ville et de pays en
pays elles apprennent toujours plus leur
aventure est fascinante elles sont
heureuses curieusement depuis plusieurs
jours les deux amis croisent des tortues
cela rend Emie mal à l'aise elle qui a
toujours vécu au milieu des humains elle
n'ose pas vraiment s'ap rocher préférant
observer ses semblables à distance au
fil des jours sa timidité s'estompe et
la curiosité aident elle finit par se
faire de nouvelles amies
Emma est ravie de voir Emy épanouie ici
au bout du monde ce soir il fait doux
Emma sourit à Emy et lui souhaite bonne
nuit les deux amis s'endorment à la
belle étoile blotti l'une contre l'autre
le lendemain lorsque Emy se réveille
emma a disparu et quand le soleil est au
plus haut dans le ciel
Emy sait que son ami ne reviendra pas
alors elle pleure longtemps toutes ces
années partagé tous ses souvenirs
IE est
triste et puis quand s'approche une
tortue puis une autre et encore une
autre
Emy comprend
Emy sourit elle pense à Emma elle pense
merci il est temps mis de commencer sa
nouvelle
vie